hi it's me thomas and today is faye
dunaway's birthday she is 80 years old
from the movie dunstan checks in with
the orangutan thing
yes it was a bad movie
dunstan checks in yes mm-hmm
and also uh oh yeah
is there such thing as a town as a
century city yes please comment down
below
yes century city yes is what i heard
there is in my head
for a long time i'm trying to get that
off my chest
and also starting um
monday actually yeah on my youtube
channel starting on
the 17th i'm gonna be a loner that means
i'm not gonna upload any more videos
until
friday what next friday whoa
whoa why
you're not uploading the whole next week
because yes that's what we do
and um is there anything else i was
saying oh yeah
today is ll cool j's birthday from a
show ncis yeah
new orleans
with the person named scott but it
starts to be
bakula it's how
but you're lucky i like you thomas
you're lucky i like you
it starts with a b it's got
[ __ ] bakula
okay it's scott bakula all right
all right all right that's who it is
thomas
come on you should know that
let me go back yeah new orleans
with the person named scott but it
starts the b
but i know how to pronounce his last
name scott yeah 1954.
so i guess we're going so i gotta go get
myself ready to work so
bye bye bye oh wait
end the video yes remember and please
put on
107 seven the boat like if i had to work
with
uh my assistant manager brandon if if he
comes in early like round
five or six remember my advice so you
don't get in trouble
please put on not scar pale sean it's
[ __ ] scott bakula god damn it
107 seven the bone the bone they will
not
play tara swift because it has to be
classic rock
and only classic rock so you don't get
in trouble
so i guess we're going so i gotta go so
bye
bye thank you thomas i don't like that
he's not gonna be here next week that
kind of bumps me out
but
that's got dracula it's got bacula
so what's going on with our uh buddy uh
mark lane the mega man x iris fan
new show that's what's going on
oh look at this here
and kevin oh oh custom wrestling
showdown vince
is in his next match up against shane
mcmahon
in a finisher only match up
and kevin owens with a dropkick on shane
mcmahon
and shane mcmahon with an elbow smack
on kevin owens
and now these two men are exchanging
blows here
it actually is better looking for the
coast to coast
no and kevin owens
rolled out of the way and now these two
men
are exchanging blows again
and kevin owens with the backdrop that
man has a family
man
and shane mcmahon with the knee to the
head
and now kevin owens and shane mcmahon
are exchanging blows again
yeah you're gonna break you're gonna
break your action figures
and kevin owens with a vertical suplex
to shane mcmahon
and now shane mcmahon with the ddt
on kevin owens
and kevin owens with the headbutt on
shane mcmahon
and now shane mcmahon with a headphone
of his own
and with a knee to the head
i know these two men are exchanging
blows again
look out here and kevin owens with the
slam
something else here dude mcmahon this is
a four minute five minute video
part one part two six minutes
i want you to break them buddy
and look out and braun strowman
immediately
with a choke slam to samoan joe
and now simone joe the knee to the head
and now samoan joe with the headbutt
it's illegal
an illegal move and look at this here
and samoan joe with a samoan drop
on braun strowman making sense and
brought strawman with the big boot to
samoan joe
and look out here i like that he goes to
press the button and ron strowman
with another choke slam to samoan joe
and now samoan joe is down for the count
one two three
four five six
and simone joe he got a count of he got
up
he got up all right that's that's my i
still haven't got in my shot and i'm
really [ __ ] bummed about that
because everybody's getting a shout out
but me everybody's
youtube fans this is
mark lane the megaman
x4 iris fan here
and i'm going to give a shout out
to the phillies fan alt
and i'm going to give a shout out
to the phillies fan alt
once again and the phillies
but not me alt but but i don't get a
shout out if you're watching this
but i don't get a shout out shout out my
friend
and thank you for watching i hope you
guys enjoyed it
and don't forget to subscribe me no
no no no hold on a second man i'm i'm
trying to help you out here
and i can't and i can't and i can't even
get
i can't even get a shout out
okay maybe this is my shout out
this is mark lane the mega man
x4 iris fan here
and i'm going to give a shout out
to sonic exe no that's fantastic
no 2008 what about day wave radio and
i'm going to give a shout out to sonic
exe oh i get it you got to repeat it but
what about day wave
what about me why don't i get a shout
out what the [ __ ]
it's sonic exe fanatic
2008 [ __ ] trenton got a shout out
everyone gets a shot up on me this
and is you for watching i get big time
by everybody hope you guys enjoyed it
and don't forget to subscribe me
and give it a shout out to sonic exe
fanatic 2008
and i've defended your honor sir
i at least deserve a shout out
i at least deserve a shout out
oh youtube fans this is
mark lane the mega man
x4 iris fan here
and i want to say thank you so much
to 862.
subscribe first you guys are awesome
yeah you're welcome jordan you're
[ __ ] everything else
and thank you again to 862
subscribers everybody
don't feel bad royce thomas didn't even
remember merch yeah well why would he
thomas is more of a date wave thing you
know thomas every once in a while do you
see why would he
shout out to mursh from night with that
[ __ ] [ __ ] you first off from 420
nice even if i'm angry it's [ __ ] nice
we do nice but also hey [ __ ] you bro
you got a shout out during the 862
subscriber special
i don't think so
happy birthday to justin the what plot
antagonist
and gamer gamer202 2021 okay but
what about me
thanks thanks
thanks so much mark
you're right he did do that
he he this is this is him
this is exactly
what he did to me it's such a [ __ ]
baller scene in a shitty movie
for me it was a tuesday